i suppose the first step is to just take
a take a super high level look at the
page and see
what top level containers we have um so
i i understand this apple uh pretty well
but uh
just from the outside you can see that
there's a couple of different panels if
you want to call them that here
we've got this left primary now we've
got a little sub menu thingy and we've
got this
rest of what we call just the main
content of the page uh you'll notice
there's a little bit of fanciness here
about giving people more screen real
estate
um but uh for for now let's just uh
let's just treat that as a single panel
so um
so that's sort of where i would start so
we've got some sort of
uh high level layout and we try to box
things out draw draw boxes around them
and so let's try and translate that into
our understanding of how we would
implement that until end so let me just
quickly
just quickly spin up the server forgot
to have that running
cool so um
so whenever we think about boxing things
out with tealand
we think of having a top level container
that will then
decide the layout for us right so here
we're going to be using
quick spoiler we're going to be using
flex for this layout so if i
just spin together a
flex container and
we know that it's going to have three
children because we've just sort of
conceptually boxed those out from just
looking at the page at a super high
level
and so let's put those together
and we've got three of those so let's
call that primary nav
this is sub menu this was the main
content
uh we get rid of hello world cool so
that's just uh
four divs one parent and three children
and if we go to
our our webpage you'll see that um that
hasn't done anything interesting for us
so that's actually just uh stuck them
all stuck all the words beside each
other
it's roughly in the right order um which
is cool but one thing i supposed to call
out first is that flex has this concept
of
directions so there's different ways in
which flex will allow you to layout the
content so if i change the default is
flex row
the two and docs are actually quite good
for this um
flex direction uh so there's a couple
different options here row call and then
reverses those which we'll get to in a
bit um so the default is row but i'll
show you what happens if we set this to
call
uh so then that'll stack them on top of
each other so that's sort of more of a
normal like block level layout right if
i put
divs on top of each other i would expect
them to sort of stack uh if i get rid of
flex
entirely that's what it would do um but
the default is actually what we care
about here so we can set this to row
um and then what we could do is just to
make this a little bit easier we can
we can give these a bit of color so we
conservative
green 200 just so we can sort of more
easily identify these while i'm talking
about them
cool um let's see here
so now you'll see what has happened
there is that uh we've colored just
the size of the div that that is needed
to contain these these items
uh so let's just give these a bit of um
artificial whip because we know we're
gonna have to fill some content into it
in a second but
um we can sort of mimic that for now by
just giving them
some fixed widths uh these are sort of
arbitrary numbers at the moment but we
can we can hone in on what those exact
pixel values should be later
and then the main content um cool and
now this last thing so you notice we've
given these first two um
we've given them fixed widths uh because
that's kind of what our
what our application structure looks
like but this last thing we don't
actually care about the exact pixel
value of what the width of that is we're
happy for that to just fill up the rest
of the space
so that arbitrary concept flex allows us
to to implement by
um by setting uh one of the flex
properties which is called flex
grow and if we go again so taylor duct's
quite nice for this
if we go to the flex docs and you'll see
the tailwind has utilities to sort of
abstract some of this away
to make this easier for us to to apply
quickly to templates
and so flex when you apply flex to a
to an element um it sets
three different properties a grow a
shrink and a basis we won't get into the
to the um technical exact descriptions
of what these are but
for now we'll we use them to to to be
useful to implement this ui
so uh here we're happy to just set flex
auto and then that'll tell it
to expand to fill up the rest of that um
direction that we have so any of the
rest of the content it'll fill up that
direction
um okay so that's cool so that's uh
we've we've got this very roughly laid
out uh these things aren't tall enough
so let's uh let's make this container a
little bit taller
um let me get the height of the screen
again until one has utilities for that
don't need to go to the ducks just now
but um so that's you know roughly the
the super high level structure so
when we looked at this layout we we
stepped back and said okay what are the
top level boxes
and now we've put those boxes in the
page we give them nice colors so that's
cool
um so where would we go from here i
suppose one thing to
touch on super quick is that so there's
a concept in flex of
um of being a flex container and playing
a flex
child so these properties that i'm
showing you here the flex one the auto
the initial
all of these that set the grow on the
shrink those apply to children
um so if i were to say get rid of this
flex container if i were to
move this parent out such that it's no
longer like a flex layout context
and these classes do nothing it means
nothing for these elements to
to have that um so let's see
if we head back to here
we can um we can see here that this is
roughly the
the right sort of content not exactly
intercoms inbox just yet but we're
getting there um
so i suppose that's like the first step
just to block out the content and then
you can progressively go down to closer
and closer layers of detail
uh to flesh out and what exactly the app
is supposed to look like
um so i suppose the easiest thing to do
here is just go left or right so let's
just mock out a few
um sort of placeholder content let's
mark out some skeleton content for
what these left nav items would look
like
and so we can do that here in our our
primary nav
sort of div so let's see
let's make these links and um
we will we'll mark this up as just
simple circles for now
give these a color
and let's see
some arbitrary width
now they'll probably want a height as
well
because what i'm doing here is just
super quickly marking out the ship
let's get rid of that right so we can
actually see what we're doing
uh i'm marking out just a few little
circles so that we can uh pretend that
those are the icons that we've
uh we've that we've handcrafted
cool so let's see here um cool so this
is i suppose another good example of um
where we we aren't going in the default
direction so here we've got a bunch of
we've got a bunch of links here a bunch
of items um and they're actually going
in the
the vertical direction right so this
flex column direction so let's uh
let's mark out a few more of these um
and by default
they should all get their own eh forgive
me
uh by default these will
here we are these won't stack i would
like to um
right so we've we've made these divs
which is handy
um but in order to to achieve this
uh to achieve this layout of where we've
got sort of a grouping up at the top and
then another grouping at the bottom
and we can use flex's
alignment and justification utility so
again tailwindox explains this sort of
for us
so there's this concept of being
on the main axis when i mentioned that
flex has a direction flexes this concept
of being on the main axis
so when you're moving along that
direction the justify properties
are what's getting used so if we were to
say
set justify end to this container
so if i make that justify and we're
gonna actually need to make this a flex
column
uh you'll see that it chucks all of our
all of our lovely little icons down to
the bottom left here
um so that's not exactly what we want
what we actually want to do is have two
separate groupings of those
um so we can do that we can artificially
wrap those
let's do that
that's great so now
let me just collapse these down so it's
a little bit easier to see
cool so uh we still set justify end here
so it's chucking them down at the bottom
um but if we look at that actually we
can see there's a couple of different
interesting ones so there's space
between the space around
and what we can actually use here is
space between so what facebook team will
do is that
all of my children um equally apportion
space such that
it divides them apart from each other so
we'll see if i set this to
between what it's going to do is because
we've only got two it's going to put one
at the top one at the bottom and all of
that space between is going to be
allocated to the middle so we've got
that that's lovely now sitting in the
middle
we can give these um
let's see
we can also then one other useful um set
of utilities that we have is the
alignment
so we've got a line items there's a
couple of different itself items content
here uh let's just go with the most
useful one for us right now
because these are the properties that we
can apply on the parent that will
change the layout of all of the children
and so here
what items does for us is it aligns
would you believe the
the children on that off axis so it
instead so if we're going in this
vertical direction the justify was
applying to where those got spaced
vertically
and the alignment will decide where they
get placed horizontally so on that off
axis again if we were
yeah let's let's not do the horizontal
um what do you call it explanation
because that'll just get too confusing
so let's uh
let's say that we can go with item
center here and we'll see what that'll
do to our
um due to our content
cool so here what it's done is that it's
moved these lovely little icons into the
very center
there um so that's great um and one
other thing we can do
is uh flex has got some handy utilities
for for space between um
so that these are essentially classes
that save us the time of having to sit
down
and um
manually put margin bottom or top on all
of these items such that we have equal
spacing between them
some fixed spacing so if i set space and
then a direction that i care about so in
this example it's y
and then two or something and we'll see
that it's gonna
it hasn't done it and cool
here we go let's make that a column
there we go cool so now it's applied
equal spacing between all of these and
you notice that i was able to set that
on the parents on this top group
and i didn't have to apply it to each
one of these children uh right so you
can change this content arbitrarily and
if at some stage you decided cool this
needs to be
you know this needs to be a little bit
bigger of a gap we can do that easily
um cool so let's uh let's do that super
easy
let's make this
uh let's actually make this give this a
bit of padding
just to give us a bit of space to the
top cool then we can apply this same
uh the same sort of spacing to the
bottom group um so this is sort of the
rough idea right of blocking out the
content and let's give ourselves a few
more lovely circles up at the top here
uh blocking out the content search that
we get a feel for the the top level
layout of the page right because you
don't need to be
um going into detail on the exact copy
the exact pixel of a
of the very precise icon at this level
right you can sort of zoom in
and get more sort of granular detail as
you go along um
so that's kind of us we've got we've got
this left now we're happy with that
let's let's give it a bit of a color
because it's got
a bit of a darker color than uh
just the white background so this
container here
we can give that let's give that a bit
of color and see what that does cool so
it's a little bit hard to see when it's
beside the screen so let's get rid of
that green for now too
and now that's sort of off gray uh two
wins different colors have a bit of a
blue hue to them um but uh
of course you can customize that to be
to be whatever you like to fit your
palette
we've of course got to customize to our
uh internal design systems um
pallets so cool so that's at the top
level
um any questions just after that uh
no i guess there's some things some
subtlety that we can come back to
in the future like the little red circle
that's kind of
positioned relatively yeah yeah
absolutely
uh but yeah that makes perfect sense and
that's that's solid start
cool cool great stuff um of course let's
give this a bit of a collet a bit of
color as well
just to start off because it has that
let's see because it's not just
white this year you notice it beside the
the main content which is actually why
um cool and then the sub menu uh nothing
super
uh complicated in here either um so
again a lot of the power flex has just
been able to say
um to break this up into different
squares of rectangles on the page and
say okay i know that there are things
either beside each other or on top
and if you were to try and sit down and
you know draw boxes around these you
want to draw them such that
you know there's no sort of overlapping
lines like say here
um i would never have uh inbox and
conversations here in the same div
um because i need
the search icon to be beside inbox uh so
those sort of things about like
slicing this up in ways that you can um
you can lay out uh you can lay out the
different
small little ui elements uh using the
flex primitives right so what do i mean
by that
so here if i just show you that simply
here make a little flex container and i
put
a little h1 in here and that says inbox
and then this other icon one thing you
showed me the other day was this concept
of hero icons
which uh absolutely fascinating and
super super quick let's
pull in let's pull in a search icon
um that's an inbox cool uh let's pull in
a search icon make this a bit smaller
um let me get rid of so many there so
at the super top level so these um
the default flex direction is again row
which is what we want right we want this
um
search icon to be beside the inbox text
not but beneath it or above it
um so that's cool let's uh let's make
this input text actually a little bit
bigger so
tailwind has some utilities or in
setting uh css properties that pertain
to font
um fonts like wheat
let's pick one of those
i believe they also have plugins for um
for setting typographic scales and all
this fancy stuff but for now let's just
mark this out with uh
with setting raw properties
text size let's see here
let's pull one of these in uh
cool so we're just super rough like this
doesn't need to be pixel perfect just
yet we're just getting a feel for the
sort of the size of these items um cool
and so this is a nice sort of example of
um there's a couple of different things
we want to change here so we're in this
like super small part of the ui that's
like we've zoomed fully into
to the two simplest things that we can
look at here um
and there's something a little bit off
right so uh for one the search icon's
right beside the inbox we'd like it to
be chucked over to the right somewhere
uh to give a little little bit more
space bring it closer to the main
content
um and it's also misaligned right so um
it's it's sitting up to the top of this
it's beside this sort of tall line
height
element and so there's a couple of
different things we need to fix here and
flex will let us do that pretty simply
um so cool so this flex container this
parent
let me just make this red to show you
what exactly we're playing with here
so this is the flex container that we
care about changing
and so again this justify between become
super helpful
justify between here that's going to
equally apportion the space between
the two children let's say for example
if i pull in another icon here
it's going to put space between them
equally
but it's quite simple often if you've
only got a couple of items to just set
justify between
one alternative way you could do this is
in saying that is to use those flex
properties that we
that we talked about before um which is
the the grow and the shrink
so if i don't want to set say justify
between here what i can do is i can say
um
that can still just be a flex container
uh it's oftentimes nice to
just be explicit about setting row just
so you can see exactly what those get
applied to
so if i were to set this to um to auto
here
that would sort of achieve the same sort
of layout for us right so
um behind the scenes it's not actually a
portioning space between these items at
the like the flexbox level
what it's doing is allowing this h1 to
actually just be that full width
right so if you see here it is way
larger than its content needs it to be
uh but that's fine too because you know
you could you could see this um
this dynamic content changing uh let's
give ourselves a little bit of padding
here
let's have a little bit just so we have
a bit of breathing room around the edges
cool um
cool so that's that's one way of doing
it uh but one thing you need to be
careful of
when when setting those is that if your
content in these
um growing containers gets too large
um it's going to start abusing the other
content in the page right so we
we we told this icon to be a certain
size but it does not care
uh flex has decided and that it can
afford to steal away a few pixels from
this
so one way to avoid that is to again
flex has some useful utilities for this
inflection utilities we can set flex
none which uh i believe what this
translates to is zero zero auto so
that's the
portion of that that we care about is
that this second property the shrink
property is set to zero which means
i cannot shrink please don't shrink me
don't steal my pixels so we can set that
on the
so we can set that on the icon flex none
uh
and now that's going to let that be the
right size
so it's like okay this thing is going to
start wrapping it's going to start
overflowing whatever
um so that's cool right so those are the
two different options where you can
have one of the pieces of content that
you're happy to take up
all of the rest of space you can either
have it grow or at the parent level
you can say justify between um we use
would you justify
uh between would we would that shrinkage
happen of the icon
yeah yeah it would yeah no exactly it
would still happen so the same shrink if
we haven't specified on the child what
exactly
if it's allowed to shrink uh the default
is for it to be allowed to
um so yeah we would still need to set
flex none
so it's actually a little bit cleaner i
think for us to just to not have that
grow and just set this to
justify between and we'll see here
that should have the exact same uh
exact same effect cool i deleted more
than i wanted to there
uh cool so that's uh so that's one of
our problems going right so that sort of
main axis problem with the justification
cool we've chucked that search icon way
over to the right there that's great
but now the alignment is off right
because this is still a pretty tall
line-height item
so let's fix that again with the align
properties
align center and so that looks lovely
but again that's
oh it doesn't what have i what have i
done uh
what have i done here item sorry
it's not align center it's items
item center there we go all right of
course because there's a couple of
different alignment properties uh if i
go back to here
um self items and content uh so again
the table inducts there's a pretty good
example of this self is basically just
if i want to be able to set the
alignment on a child by child basis so
here you can see that two
has decided to be up at the top um and
there's uh let's see what's the other
one called
it's it's so seldom that we use these
that i i don't think i've actually ever
written this this tailwind class
definition for cut
for uh for the content but um basically
this
uh describes what happens to the uh to
the block as a whole
so if you can see here all right exactly
that yeah so it's not being applied to
the to the children themselves but to
that entire container
um but yeah for our intensive purposes
you can get
90 of the way more than 90 of the
weather by just using justified content
on the line items
so that is what we're going to do um and
again that shows sort of the power just
being able to mark these things out
super quickly using
a handful of a handful of properties
okay so we can get rid of this right
here because we're happy with how that
looks now
and so that's one container up at the
top let's give ourselves another
um class if i could
spell that that'd be great um so again
we don't
need to go into a bunch of detail here
i'm not it's not super interesting to
flesh out a bunch of this stuff a lot of
the patterns that i've just
like explained up here will apply to
this as well right you can see a bit of
content to the left being spaced between
some content to the right and
so you trust me let's just put some
squares in the page you know trust me
that we we we know how to build this and
then we can move on to more interesting
uh parts of the time we can back to them
if we if we need to if we have time
um bg red and let's give this a height
some fixed height uh we don't
necessarily care what that looks like
that's just some divs in the page bg red
that's a good idea yeah we have
customized this pilot internally so we
don't necessarily use the default ones
so i keep forgetting uh
cool so those are stacked together let's
uh
let's change that such that we give
these a little bit of breathing room
um flex let's call again so we're
looking at this entire
sort of off-white container and what we
can do again is just set
these space between utility so space y
let's give that for something right and
that'll put even spacing between them so
that's lovely
and one thing that you might notice is
that there's there's more space between
the inbox and this first sort of group
of sub-menu
sections than between the sub-menu
sections themselves
so you can do that using um regular old
margin utilities so this top level
that we've sort of isolated from the
rest of it you could just say
let's just pick an extreme example to
show margin bottom 16
right so you can you can use those in
conjunction with the space y
uh again margins will collapse where
they need to but they
you can just specify one that's a little
bit bigger than you need it to be
so let's say six here it gives it a
little bit more breathing room
and not the entire margin but just
margin bottom
um cool so that's sort of roughly
roughly in the right direction so you
trust me that we know how to make those
uh make those squares look correct and
we can move on to the main content
um so cool let's do that so
let's get rid of this garish blue and
let's see we'll make this background
white uh you'll notice
uh i'm sorry i'm typing utility classes
here to achieving a design that we
haven't actually fully looked at yet so
you notice that this we've got sort of a
rounded bit of a container
um and it's got a bit of a border and
it's actually got a bit of a drop shadow
here as well or sorry box shadow
um so let's do that surrounded by
content
would you believe i'm just using
arbitrary nouns here and applying them
to the div and it's working
um but no yeah two one's got some pretty
good default naming for these things but
yeah so
uh what those utilities are doing it's
allowing us rounded corners
uh it's allowing us to um to specify
these utilities right so before without
tailwind you would have had to have
created a class for this
um dip out to css switch from the
template out to another file
and specify this on some class so you
know um our existing app might have like
min mina um
content uh and then you would apply like
rounded and shadow and stuff to that
what we can do is we can compose a bunch
of different utilities
uh to achieve that so um what we've
currently got
is actually uh not super
not super correct so actually why
why has not rounded anything for us bg
white flecks auto
mean content is it actually rounded oh
it is it is it's just tiny let's make
that much bigger
um forget the t-shirt sizing scale it
uses is that it yeah coca-cola so that's
it
and let's give that a border so it's a
little bit easier to see
border red and we should probably have a
border before we tell it that it's red
of course red isn't a thing that exists
in this palette so let's go right 200.
cool so we can see now let's make it a
little bit darker actually
contrast is important cool so we can see
what's happened there is that we've got
a border
uh and we've got a border radius at the
corner which is great
um but we're actually we're rounding
every single one of these corners so the
default rounded class will apply to just
the entire element uh but there are some
modifiers in those classes that allow us
to just
do the uh to the corners that we care
about
so let's see any one of these examples
have exactly what we want look at this
rounded tl
uh so instead of rounded excel we can go
around a tl and then excel so that's the
direction or the side and then the then
the size so cool now if we go back to
here we can see
cool so it's just this one that we care
about um
you're you're uh probably too young to
remember this but have you ever
like achieved rounded corners by opening
up photoshop and
doing the render quarters and cutting
them up i
have not that's how we used to do it in
the day you'd create a table and you'd
have the top left and the top right
and you did it it was it was a nightmare
this is oh you'd rather eyes out a
little
yeah yeah but that's the way we used to
do it
boy oh boy no thankfully that was there
like that was before my time now we can
just set a single
a single class and it'll do it for us um
yes this is cool one thing that this i
don't actually know if you'll see here
but
let's uh let's make this a little bit
easier to see by making this dark
part of me darker um we're uh we're
actually bleeding through so
the um we're not so this sort of visual
uh design here but it has us to believe
is that
uh this main content is actually sitting
atop of this like
sub menu section uh and you can see on
the actual app here that this
like seamlessly uh is the same color
transitions in through
so this is actually if i go back to our
app here simply incorrect right so this
is not bleeding through at all so that's
the sort of you know pixel perfect stuff
that
we we can come back to in the end but
because we actually have a fix for it
right now let's just do that so the way
that we get around this in in our app is
that to say that the entire page
actually has a given background so you
might apply this to the body or whatever
um 200 let's just exemplify that by
making that
red 800. um
so you see here that now this is
applying to just this section that's
behind
this uh this border radius uh cool so
let's do that
uh let's set that to whatever it is
oops uh it's like 100 so whatever the
the sub menu section was uh and where
was our sub menu here it's hiding down
here cool
um cool so like we're most of the
structure there to like
we've sort of like it's this this sort
of
mode of thinking of like i don't
actually care what the what the copy
says what the
exact text is but if i'm blocking out
the high level things about the page
you can tackle the layout separate from
the content right so you can
you can portion the section such that uh
you've got the like you could argue
we're maybe 20
of the way there to the full layout of
the page and we've only applied what
how many like uh we've got
oops i'm recording a macro that's simply
not what i wanted uh one second
we've got like 18 dibs cool so 18 divs
has gotten us to most of the way of the
page
um so it's just sort of this incremental
box things out and uh and you could
flash out
the pixel perfect detail later so let's
get rid of this garish border
um let's make that some other color
actually the default border should
probably be fine
and we actually don't want to border the
whole way around this thing we actually
only care about
the left um actually that's not fully
true there's a bit of a cheat you'll see
that there's uh it sort of tapers as it
goes up to the top
how we actually achieve this in the app
is that we've got a pixel a single pixel
um
box shadow but we don't need to get into
uh
that exact just yet so just trust me
that we can achieve this whatever we'd
like to but
and this shadow is actually not super
[Music]
super close to what we have in the app
so let's see here
what do we have
shadow in there cool these dogs are cool
um
so we've got a couple of different uh
options here let's go for xl
that seems close enough shadow xl
uh again so this is just a utility for
not having to run around and type out
all of this so i'm creating a new custom
class for this and then applying these
arbitrary pixel values that i'm sure
look great and
uh a highly printable designer has
handpicked uh we can just drop those on
and of course you can configure this to
whatever you're up uh whatever your
app's needs are
uh if you've got some proprietary border
shadow technology
feel free to set that either um cool so
we've still got our main content
um and that's looking close right so
we're getting we're getting there so
uh let's see um
cool so i suppose that's another so
that's sort of a
milestone we can step back and say cool
so at the high level we've blocked out
a good chunk of the app so we've flashed
out some placeholder content for the
for the navigation and the sub menu and
now we're into
another sort of zoom level so now we've
got a separate pin on the app that we
can
take this sort of top level okay what
are the main boxes
uh approach to to laying this out so um
if we go again unlock uh if you wanted
to you could be cheeky and
like just get rid of that entire menu
right so all we care about is what's in
this section here
um i'm not going to do that because the
zoom's awkward to scroll through but
uh so looking at this main content we
see it's got a
sort of a similar layout to the previous
one it's still in this sort of row
direction we've got these sort of panels
that are beside each other
so we can pretty easily mock that out
too let's do that
let's bring back our trusty uh
rgb divs
i'm just gonna bring my puppy out to the
back for a few minutes
excellent no worries
g
cool and we are let's see what we're
rendering we're rendering nothing
because these
these days don't actually have any
content so that's not interesting at all
so let's say um left center
right and now you'll see uh
okay good example these are on top of
each other right because we're not in a
flex container so these again these flex
properties
we set this flex auto um we set the flex
auto on this sort of main content
div container that's a that's a flex
child property so that defines
how it's going to be laid out with
respect to its parent that doesn't turn
this div itself into a flex container
that
that setting that property does not in
any way change how
this element's children are going to be
laid out so if we want to make
this a flex container we have to also
say flex right so you
you set this flex utility class and
again this isn't magic this is
we just go to display um it's the exact
same as block or inline right if this
was a span you would have you would have
inline um
you could turn it into a table if you
wanted to right so setting flex
literally just sets display flex that
property uh and then you can use a bunch
of the other utilities uh to
to augment how that will actually get
laid out so
i've got a big side menu stuff here but
uh you'll see yeah so flex wrap
direction grow shrink all of this
um utility stuff even order uh we don't
use that all that often but
um yeah this stuff like this so flex
isn't magic it's just setting display
flex
um and if i were to do that and set that
so the default is row so what it's going
to do is it's going to make this nice
for us again and chuck those beside each
other so let's
let's be just a little bit explicit and
say row there
um cool so these aren't filling up the
full space
uh we could do that if we wanted to
again to
exactly mimic our previous uh layout
we could make that flex auto to make
that grow out to the right
it's not doing that why isn't it doing
that flex row because i haven't set flex
through and i haven't stuff like solder
on that okay
cool um missing space cool so
now that's chucked that right box out to
the far right um
let's take a look at the app i don't
want to split this up if i
recall correctly so there's some
responsive breakpoints and stuff in the
app we don't need to
fully get into you know how that works
um or what those exact pixel values or
percentage values are
let's just say that this is roughly a
fifth a fifth on the right and then
three fifths in the middle uh some
arbitrary approximation we can we can
hone in on what exactly that is later
um how do you type that one over five
we don't use this super often but we can
we can use them here
so let's do that and then this doesn't
need to be flex auto anymore
does that work cool
cool so that works um and again one
thing to notice is that we set the
border radius on the parent so if we
actually needed this
left red thing to have a background we
need to set a border radius on it as
well
or to set you know overflow hidden on
the parent app up yeah yeah we don't
need to get into it
um but you'll notice this deja vu we're
sort of in the same
place that we were at the very start of
like we've blocked out this content
and we've given it some lovely lovely
colors
and now we can flesh that out with some
more interesting uh
some more interesting content so let's
at a super high level let's pass through
that so let's
this is not red these colors we do not
care about at all
and there's actually color on this on
this rightmost boil
so that's great same sort of gray as
this i think don't know what number we
picked for that
uh bulgaria yeah so let's set that to
gray
yeah close enough cool and now this
center as well we can set
it's got a bit of a border left and
right uh can you go lr
i don't crawl let's hope so
you don't think so okay let's uh let's
split those out
i'll try it i mean let's let's find out
there's only one way to know
uh yep you're right does it doesn't work
cool so that's border allen border r to
to split those out that's far too heavy
let's make that a little bit smaller
um still feels a bit too heavy
yeah don't need to be picks perfect here
it's a matter of changing a single value
later
um i've skipped one and
jumped right out of where i want to be
cool so that's that's close enough right
so we've we've
uh demarcated these separate sections
i've got the left center on the right
um so let's uh
flash through this so there's a little
bit of more interesting stuff to look at
here in terms of flex layout because
we've got uh
overflow and stuff so let's let's get
into that cool so
cool let's do that let's see so we can
leave those
two as they are let's give us a little
bit of breathing room between these
let's change this left to be
uh to have some content right so when we
look at this
um it's sort of more interesting right
because as we've already mentioned
there is uh there's overflow happening
and we'll notice there's sort of this
like static fixed header up at the top
and you could think of that as being
sticky it's not really it's just sort of
fixed and then this section
scrolls um as you can see by where the
the scroll bar is actually placed here
it's only
in this container so let's do that we
can mock up
a div and a div below it and this one is
allowed to scroll so let's
let's mark that out
we'll probably want to give this a class
later
i should really set up my editor to
automate this better
my uh my expansions are not they're not
what they used to be
um let's see cool so what has that done
for us
absolutely nothing excellent because
there's no content in there so this is
top
rolling bottom uh
and that has placed them on top of each
other again because this is just a
regular layout mode if we had set this
to flex
it would chuck those beside each other
which is cool it's not actually what we
want though
um but what we can do is uh set this
back to the call direction
and then i don't necessarily actually
need to use flex here uh
and as an example let's not let's just
let's just not use it so flex isn't
actually
uh yeah
yeah we don't actually need to so let's
let's do this here um
so let's set this to some fixed height
uh what should this be 16 we'll make it
give it a color
again just to show what the content is
top uh width actually no that's not what
i wanted we're going in this direction
either heights are cool that's some some
height should actually probably be a bit
bigger
with 24 forget which values we have
again we've customized these numbers
cool so yeah
top and then the scrolling bottom so
let's uh
let's make some content here um some
arbitrary content just for now just to
show exactly what this uh
this scrolling container will look like
as a class uh what do we want this to be
um we'll give it some fixed height
again these won't be blue yet but just
uh just to show um
i can't spell but you'll trust me that
that's going to be okay
uh and so this is the container that we
want to scroll so
we probably have so let me pasting a
bunch of times let's um
uh how do i do this
range 100 i probably want to open a
block as well
uh this is just a little bit of amber
templating language we i don't need to
get into the specifics of what that does
for us it's not tailwind specific
but just know that it's gonna spit out a
bunch of uh bunch of containers for us
here
uh a tags must have yes yeah indeed they
must
uh cool so we've got a bunch of stuff
here and we've very very successfully
destroyed our layout um
so what's what's happening here is that
we haven't actually specified what we
want this container to do whenever it
doesn't have enough space to to contain
our content
um tailwind has some nice utilities for
that
would you believe they've sat down and
thought about this stuff uh
cool so we've got we can we can set
based on the direction we can set any
one of these overflow properties
and so let's go for overflow y
auto again x and y those two those two
directions
um overflow y auto
and now that has not worked cool so
let's actually make this a flex
container so so
the the trick here is that we've told it
to overfl overflow by auto but
this um full like left section parent
hasn't actually set a fixed height on
this thing at all
i suppose we could mimic that by setting
this to like h
it's screen perhaps will that do what we
want no it won't okay cool so let's
let's uh let's forgo that let's fall
back to
to the safe to the cf happy uh known
of using flex to apportion these call
please cool so
um let's call and again we're because we
already know that there's some content
beneath
that's gonna want to grow to be as big
as it can right there's a dynamic
contents popping in these can grow
arbitrarily large
i'm going to set flex known on this
on this top container to say don't steal
any content from this and then this can
be flex auto again so just say
the top thing is some fixed height um
but the rest of this
just fill up to whatever space you can
um so here we are okay cool right
we're back in we're back into safe
territory here we haven't destroyed our
layout this is now scrolling for us
uh you'll notice that these are actually
beside each other uh it's because i mean
these a tags that's fine
if you wanted to you can make those
block uh and again that's just your way
of setting this uh oh
well that's a good example let's put
that back uh and let's
let's see what's happened here our sub
menu has been absolutely destroyed
um and that's because at the very top
level we hadn't actually encountered
this
necessity for flex and done yet right so
let's let's just set that so beside
these widths so remember
flex none so say do not do not steal
pixels for me go away please thank you
um
so where did we have our wits here yeah
flex none
and i will notice that this will expand
out cool so we've told it
these are fixed static content on the
left don't steal any pixels from them
please flex um cool so
now let's make these back into blocks
again um
again we're not being super accurate
here on like the semantic structure of
the page
it's uh it's it's
as close as it needs to be for us to lay
out this uh to lay out this content
and of course we can tweak this the
structure afterwards
so cool so that's uh that's the top
level
uh we've got these things scrolling so
that's great like these conversation
cards they're
looking pretty ugly right now but let's
uh let's make those not blue
let's give this a border
border bottom yeah cool why not
cool so those those are close enough
let's give it some padding and again you
can tweak with
tweak these values as much as you need
to
just get a little bit closer to this
design i suppose one little bit of
flourish here that we have
is this um this concept
of like this uh this little
selected state so this is i suppose one
sort of interesting thing to
discuss is your ability to use tailwind
in conjunction with like
um a component library or a way of
abstracting
some reusable parts of your template out
into into components um
so here you can imagine that this
like you could insert instead of us so
once once we get this perfect and we've
fleshed out all the exact layout and the
the template for this like link to a
conversation
um you could pull out a new component
and encapsulate all of the
like the layout are the
the render specific logic that's only
related to the to this card
right so like a selected state a hovers
date setting the colors all of those you
could um
actually obviously it's not a good
example because we can set that with
just pure css but it likes this the
selected state for example to set this
border
where we can conditionally set those and
you could pull that out into its own
component encapsulate that and have that
and have that borrowed away such that
you can just invoke one of those instead
of having to
have that live at the top level but we
don't need to get into that now let's
just
super quickly uh show that we can
achieve this
and this little
tiny little pc ui flourish of setting
the
border l some size um
200 something more
more saturated let's see uh cool
and that doesn't care about that at all
because there's no actual content inside
it cool
this typo is going to live forever if i
don't fix it
conversation card uh cool and now uh
yeah cool so that makes sense we've told
it to put this lovely border on the left
but we actually applied the padding to
the parent so let's uh let's move that
down
cool now now we're getting closer um and
this doesn't actually need to be h16
anymore we can actually factor out the
content of this right so
uh let's see what we have what structure
do we have so
uh again the same sort of design uh of
like
if you zoom into just this level so just
this blue background thing
um how would you draw the boxes such
that you can
actually put the content in there so
again you would never really have this
nikola tesla and the avatar
be in the same container as this like
long form content right because
there's no way that those two could be
there if the if the icon wasn't also
and that's sort of in a different flow
direction right so you couldn't have
these stacked on top of each other and
then
somehow have this uh this like time
stamp or the
the little tick anywhere else in the
flow so you have to sort of box these
out such that those are um
so those make sense uh in in in terms of
like the super simple primitives of just
like
things are either on top of or beside
each other and we can space them
wherever we want to but there's no
getting around the fact that
these two have to be an ascendive um of
course you could
you could get into fancy stuff with
relative and absolute positioning and
like pixel perfect choosing exactly
where these things are going to go but
for the simplest flows and for the most
sort of maintainable flows
just use the layout primitives um so
let's do that let's
let's super quickly mark those out
again uh you'll be sick of seeing these
colors by the end of it but
uh just as an example of what i'm
talking about
top and bottom
top and bottom cool so the red and the
green here's what i'm talking about so
this the red is going to be the nikola
tesla and the click and the
the bottom is going to be this sort of
snippet preview of what's in the
conversation cool so let's uh
give it a conversation card sounds like
that typo wouldn't have lived long at
all
um and now we can think of these things
sort of separately right so we don't
actually care uh what's in this bottom
one yet but we can think of this one
uh now that we've zoomed in and we know
that this red part is the thing that
we're
we're designing here uh let's see
what this is actually supposed to look
like right so we've got some content on
the left and some content on the right
so
before we even decide what that content
is we can already sort of tell what we
what we're going to lay this out to so
it's going to be flex electro and
justify between and we could even be so
bold as to go one more step and say
we know that we're going to want these
all to be on the same sort of line like
we're going to want these all to be in
the same line in that direction so
um that involves aligning them across
the cross direction to be centered so
let's
item center right so before we even put
any content on our page
um we know that let's just say
so that goes doesn't go away
but i'm close enough board dom a
let's say that we have a little span
here
a and then b the class at the bottom
dave is
a little messed up ah it is how did i do
that
excellent cool uh thanks for that so
let's see it'd be
uh so before we'd even decided what this
content needed to be we could take a
look
at the at the design and say cool so we
know these things need to be laid out in
a certain way so it doesn't exactly
matter what the
the final content is going to be but we
can set that uh we can set the layout
ahead of time
so let's uh let's flash that out so
let's say that this
is a little uh little circle do we have
an avatar icon perhaps in here icons
person no we don't appear to let's pick
some arbitrary let's say that everyone
wears a hat
uh cool so we can put that
you can put that here these shouldn't be
spans
again so um when we're inside of flex
like the semantic meaning of a span
versus a div like spam doesn't give us
anything that the display mode is going
to be changed like the the parent
is deciding how we're going to be laid
out so it might as well just be a div
for these
static content especially like uh images
like we have here
so let's do this also
and let's this is uh
this is a container so let's say
nicola tesla cool let me turn on
wrapping so that we don't need to look
at that full svg content
uh let's make this a bit small so let's
see what's happened here how close are
we now
um cool so those are on top of each
other uh
so let's fix that that's cool
so again at the top level we had sort of
laid this out as one item
um but
let's see i suppose this might be
another example of where we
the question of justification versus the
letting one of the children grow could
be could be uh
could be had of like if we allow this
sort of name section to grow then we
don't need to worry about
this being a container and this being a
separate container and then this having
its own sort of layout
so let's do that let's simplify this
down to to this just being
if you see what i'm deleting here just
this div
being gotten rid of and now this here
can flex grow
so that middle bit the name conflicts
grow and now we can get rid of the
the justification because now that the
test and the middle part is going to to
fill up the full space
cool so we're close enough there let's
see like um absolutely too small
and again this is just a placeholder no
it'll be dynamic content coming from the
the the user profile but we can very
easily mark that together
and again if we wanted to uh you could
just set like margin right of something
here on this
icon to give a little bit of breathing
room to on that um
we could also just set our space
utilities right so here in this
container
space x of two or something all right
and i'll put space between these all
um cool so that's
uh sort of close uh this text is
actually quite big flex grow
can we make that smaller oops i
have caps lock on not a good idea uh
yes um can i get a little bit smaller
cool so that looks good um
i can't it's actually not as it's not as
visually similar as i had hoped but
you'll trust me that we could we could
fill that with anything that we wanted
to
uh cool and then this example of this uh
is another nice example of like
truncation happening so let's do that
too so let's
uh see in this bottom green container
that we're that we're working on now we
can again
sort of see that this is moving in the
horizontal direction so the flex row
direction
so let's do that
and it doesn't need to be green anymore
which is great
and we can let's see pull in another
icon
let's pick this one and we'll make it a
little bit smaller because
it is a smaller sort of admin preview so
and now we have some other content so
this can be a div or whatever
we don't actually care um
and we're gonna want it to to grow to
fill whatever
um so this is
so message content um so let's see
is that so that happily enough that
string is just small enough to not get
truncated yet but we'll get to that in a
sec
uh go so the same sort of stuff has
happened here where the alignment is off
because line heights are a thing uh
so this is actually really tiny um can
we make these a little bit bigger sorry
moving pixels around so that this this
example is a little bit better
but um so the alignment thing we're
talking about
items center um
cool so those are beside each other and
we can put a little bit of space between
those
space x two love it um
might actually need to be a bit smaller
um but again so we're sort of shifting
around pixels here um
so oh yeah i suppose that's one thing i
haven't really touched on is like where
do these numbers come from like one what
is that what is that unit uh
so that if we look at the two index uh
a good example of this is um so the
default is for it to be related to
relative um element unit so that's based
on the
the size of the body your of your
application or your page
and we've actually internally got these
mapped to direct pixel values so that
they map our four pixel grid internally
so like
px1 is just four pixels for us but uh
the default config is um
totally fine we can use it here it's
it's a close enough approximation we
don't need to go fiddling with our
config right now but
just in case you're wondering where
those where those values are coming from
that's it
and it's the same sort of units so these
padding and the
what else do we have here yeah like the
padding is between the margins they're
all using the same sort of unit system
uh so a one here means a one up there as
well so that's super handy to
you know once you get into the flow of
like understanding you know
visually that you know let's say uh
this gap is either a one or a two then
it becomes just sort of second nature to
just sort of uh
drop those in and of course you can
tweak those if they're not exactly pixel
perfect
um cool so let's we've gotten to that
so let's make this some arbitrarily long
content that's going to
it's going to overflow uh so that's uh
not exactly what we wanted okay so
another example of our
lovely little icon getting terribly
abused here by
this flex grow so again
flex none you're not allowed to make
this smaller
that'll get bigger cool and tailwind
also has
truncation utilities so
if i literally just put the word
truncate on it as if it's a
command it will uh
i can set truncate on this big long
overflowing piece of content
and it'll truncate for me so that's cool
uh the text is actually a bit too big so
let's
see what tealand tells us about that
how small can we get text access
that seems usual useful uh
cool how are we looking now close enough
right so that's that's that's super
close uh
there's some spacing between these uh so
we can again do that at the top level
so uh this is the container that we care
about
um space
space y of two or four it actually looks
quite big and not exactly
sure 16 close enough all right so if we
zoom out sorry i've been zoomed in there
so it's sort of hard to see the
perspective
um but we're sort of close enough there
we're uh we're roughly on the right size
we might actually from all my zooming in
be a bit uh
a bit too small still but let's let's
tweak that a little bit
so you can make this history or whatever
and again so it's not exactly important
that we get this design to match up
perfectly it's more than like the
the principles of getting to
translate a picture in the worst case
just a you know a
jpeg of a design and be able to
translate that into boxes on the page
such that you can
have these things be interactive um cool
and this be
that by default i think is some content
let's see
oh yeah it's some time stamp so b let's
set that to
five hours excellent um
and again that could be a span or
whatever but that
isn't super important for us here in
this demo just in this uh
but what is important is that it's
actually the right size
so we can make that a bit smaller uh and
is it actually
cool yeah it is okay this is another
good example of being able to use the
two one utilities to
to configure color here so this is sort
of like a it's a great sort of a
de-emphasized text so let's see um
we can use text color and this you can
pull in any of our palette values that
exist so
let's do that
200 don't know what exactly is good here
again these will have been hand chosen
to have contrast ratios that are
distinctly better than this
so let's actually do that uh again this
doesn't need to be the exact shade of
gray here but we will
uh we'll get close to it six maybe
that's reasonable
close enough uh so yeah for this demo
it's close enough
um cool let's actually give us
a different icon
circle oh user circle
ah i was searching for person okay cool
all right so we found a perfect uh
in our spelunking we found a perfect uh
icon to set as a placeholder here
again on the left side we actually just
used this as a
as a circle but we'll be a little bit
higher res here so we'll set that to
five cool
and and where was this other one down
here we'd set this to
set u to this cool and now
how are we looking look at those those
are those are users if i've ever seen
them
those are icons great um because of
those are scrolling we've actually what
we've done is we've set
this border on all of them so we can
sort of mark out what that would look
like using say conditionals so say
um as
i some index uh so we can arbitrarily
pick the second one
to uh to get to the border and this
boardrail border blue
um ah let's see here
if that's that then you can get this
lovely little a little bit of flourish
to show that you're selected
and let's see so now only one of them
cool
that's one index excellent um
so now this is getting that and what it
also gets is a bit of background color
so
it actually gets to keep the bg blue
200. do we want to apply the border
on all of them so that it isn't shifted
in
a couple of people ah great idea cool so
we can border l
uh here cool so what gavin's has just
brought up here is that so say
if we were to only apply okay let's
let's actually visualize that using the
the inspector um so it might be a little
bit hard to notice here because it's
only a couple pixels but
um all of this content is out of line
with
um with this item because we've set
border l
two on this which means that all of the
content inside this so this container is
actually two pixels smaller than
the rest of all of these so let me show
you here
so if we get down to brass tags and see
what the actual sizes say
for example like this container is
um what's that being computed to 223.8
and this boil is different oh seriously
okay yeah because we've got a box sizing
it's it's computing those is the same
but if we were to look at
say for example this this content will
be different so this
uh here we've got uh 137.8
and in this one it is um
199 right so here we've lost those two
pixels because we've said that
only the selected ones have this so all
of the content has to be a little bit
smaller to compensate
uh but of course we can fix that by just
always applying it and having it only be
visible if uh
if we actually want to see it so let's
do that supporter left two will always
be a thing
i think by default that'll actually give
us a color on that border it will cool
so we can we can knock that off by
saying
um
probably set the color to transparent
yeah cool so let's do that
so then the border color and so if
uh so again if we so this uh might be
look a little bit strange but this is
basically saying if this is the selected
card whatever abstraction we have around
that this would probably live in a
component
and we want it to have the border and a
background um
but if it's not that then we can set the
border to transparent so
let's show that cool so now those are
all perfectly in line if i pull it over
here and scroll over to the left
you see that those are all perfectly
perfectly in line
uh which we didn't have before um
cool so that's you know that's close
we've got selected states we can
conditionally apply these
utility classes to get sort of more
interesting interactions with the app so
that's cool
um so let's see here
how are we getting on so yeah that's
close uh
and we can also do hover states right so
if you if you notice i don't know if the
the contrast is good enough in the
recording to show but if i hover over
these
um the background is changing ever so
slightly so let's uh let's set that as
well
so um and that doesn't matter oh it does
matter whether we're selected we don't
want to change the border when we're
selected so let's on hover
uh so these are sort of the prefix uh
are the where are those documented
oops oh there's a good tutorial for you
so let's let's
uh hover let's see if you do like
background you'll get
a hover pseudo class background
size goodness
forgive me i'm having trouble with
algolia
class i think if you scroll down there
should be a hover there
there we go yeah cool so they've got
they got demos of this
um of setting this sort of prefix to
utility class
allows it to to be applied whenever um
whenever you have interactions there's
also ones for
for focus uh and some other states and
they've also got focus
within uh on some of the some of the
newer builds but uh
hovers what we care about here so let's
use that um and so again so we're sort
of in the second leg of the conditional
because we only want to actually change
the hover state whenever we're not
selected right we don't want to
if we had a blue background because it
was selected hovering over that we don't
want it to change to some light gray
just because we're hovering over it
we're ready on that
so let's go uh let's set this to some
arbitrary number as well
again nothing's perfect doesn't exactly
have to match but it's close enough if i
show you here
you'll see the difference um between
those two let's actually make that super
visible
let's go to our let's go to our good
friend ready 800 just to show that uh
just make sure it comes through on the
video uh again right so that's just
applying the hover pseudo selector and
we can uh
super easily mock that up so that's cool
right so we've got
the scrolling list of conversations uh i
won't spend any more time getting pixel
perfect on this we've sort of gone to
the level of detail that i think is
useful for
for this demonstration but um let's
super quickly mock uh
mark this side um actually is there
anything interesting happening there
there isn't really right so
uh do you think we should flesh this out
instead of just moving on to
some more interesting content over here
or um yeah i think it's we reckon
it's better to do the more interesting
stuff yeah if we have time at the end we
can come back
either wise just leave it as a block i
think it's fine cool cool um
cool so let's do that so uh we can
actually knock out this
part super easy it's uh pretty actually
simple it's
just a fully overflowing container so
let's uh let's do that
um so again this is our rightmost
container we've got some gray
we can already tell we're going to want
it to overflow in this direction
and so the difference between auto and
scroll here is that
if it doesn't actually have enough
content to need to scroll it won't give
a give a
scroll bar on certain browsers which is
nice
um so that's cool so we can set auto on
that and we tend to default to that in
our app but
it's mostly personal preference i
suppose uh course we can overflow
and we'll put some content in here so
let's see um
i don't actually care exactly what's in
here i'm not going to flesh out the um
i'm not going to measure the content
because that's not the interesting part
of this
of this exercise cool so let's um make
this a container as well
and one thing to look at so i'm sort of
a portioning off one container for the
top and then one big container for the
bottom that contains all of these sort
of inbox card style things
um so let's do that so this top
container it's got some fixed height
um no it doesn't actually uh
yeah let's let's let's uh
let's stick with um flex
part of me
let's call one second
cool so flex call and um
we don't care about space between those
just yet flexing on
border b
and uh what color is this
probably again so i'm being specific
here about setting a border
just because we're on sort of already a
gray background so it needs to be sort
of darker than normal to um
to actually be visible otherwise it
would just be the same sort of color
cool so we've got that border
and again sort of just marking out this
content um
and i won't get into even flashing out
this counter right because it's the same
as we've seen before
using the the tailwind flex primitives
to
to put things beside each other and then
space them out in in the ways that we
care about
um okay so that's that content on the
top and then this bottom section
um let's see what this looks like so
we're going to want to have that be a
call as well
and then we can super easily set space
um
sy probably two or something four who
knows um
but what we're going to have in here is
a bunch of cards right so let's keep our
we shall not need a hundred but we'll
we'll repeat a couple of these
just to mock out to show what that looks
like
each let's give ourselves 10. um
we don't care which one of these we're
on uh so let's
do that i know don't care about the
contents of it yet so
we're gonna want to be white it has a
border
and it's going to be rounded cool so
that's sort of how quickly you can mock
out a little card let's give it some
content
and let's see what that looks like
cool so that's uh those are some cards
they're not tall enough let's make
those pretend to be some certain height
64. and
we don't want the flex parent to be
actually able to change that 64 for us
uh cool so we've got some cards here
padding's off so on this
actually yeah so on this container we
can put the padding
uh we can't put it on the full like
right container because like we've got a
border here that we want to be the full
width so
you know that sort of stuff um let's put
some padding on this container as well
this card just so that we have some
content there
um cool so those are cards on the right
that's cool uh we've got our scrolling
container we're super super close to the
like 40 000 foot view of what the what
that layout is supposed to look like
um so that's great is there anything
super interesting in these cards in
terms of layout
i don't think so right so it's it's all
stuff that we've seen before i got
truncation you've got
stuff beside each other and one thing to
touch on is that normally when you're
truncating things it's useful to have
like tooltips to show people what the
truncated content is actually going to
look like we won't get into that detail
that's not necessarily uh tailwind
layout flex applicable so let's let's
not dive into that
so let's just say just before we move
off this
is there an easy way to make the card
content that text
uh centered both vertically and
horizontally
yeah absolutely good question so um cool
so
one thing you'll notice so so the answer
to this is that yes we can use these um
flex justification and alignment
utilities
that we've used to like space between uh
and center things before
if we set those both to center that'll
put it perfectly in the center for us so
let's do that and just again to
exemplify the fact that these things
only do stuff for us whenever we're
um let's see
justify that these only do things for us
whenever we are a flex container i will
show you what that looks like
justify content on item center all right
so we've applied those classes uh but
that's done nothing for us right because
these
justify center and item center these
only apply to flex
parents right so this again so setting
flex none here
has not uh has not turned it has not
changed our like
rendering um system uh we're still like
a block level element our content will
just flow normally
um but as soon as we make this a flex
container
if i could stop navigating away from the
file
this then becomes flex and it centers so
um just to show the justification we can
chuck these both down to the end
as well super simply and then that'll
chuck it down into the bottom right hand
corner for us so again you can play
about with any of these um
with any of these properties but uh yeah
at a super simple level
card content we can check that in the
center by just using uh justify
and align items so cool
um that's it so that's like most of most
of the inbox there right like ignoring
all of these uh
little lovely little red things that we
we haven't fleshed out because they
aren't super interesting to dive into
just yet
uh it's just the actual part the most
functional part of the inbox which is
the the conversation stream like the way
that you contract with the messages and
respond to people
um that we can uh that we can lay out
next so
uh so that's cool so um we can
focus our attention to just one part of
the page so it's sort of that this sort
of like mental exercise of
abstracting away a lot of detail like it
all of this content doesn't apply to
to any of the layout here so i can i can
sort it at different zoom levels block
these
uh block these boxes on the page out
such that i'm thinking about just this
layout
um which is nice right so what do we
have here we've got some scrolling
container which
uh it's actually only this content here
so if i can show you there it's actually
only this um
this container here and we've got some
fixed content at the bottom and
this little text area the composer area
and this sort of again sort of a static
or a fixed header at the top it's not
fixed it's not like floating or anything
it's actually just like
this is the scroll container um so it's
just uh
another flex container so we can we can
mock this up again
let's do that
um so again we can before we put any
content in there we can we can tell that
this is going to be a flex call right so
we know that we're going down in the
direction and let's uh
let's give ourselves some content some
arbitrary height
because we know that that's fixed we
already know that we're not going to
want our scrolling container to be able
to steal any pixels away from this
and um let's go again to our
venerable friend red background
and let's do some fixed content at the
bottom as well
cannot type excellent cool and this
doesn't have a height this is actually
just going to flex to auto
and we already know that it's going to
want to be able to overflow
so we can set that right out the bat
right before we get any content in here
and we actually do need to have some
content otherwise these will just
not be a good example for us so let's
pull that up
and what have i changed do i have a typo
somewhere
oh i'm editing my sidebar over here cool
what did i change up here cool so let's
uh let's back some of those changes out
let's uh let's pull this up and pretend
that this is actually our
uh the boy that we care about w305
what else to be set yeah we're gonna
take all of these
forgive me i was editing the wrong div
there would you believe uh
that can happen oops
and now all of this stuff that no longer
applies to
to this content what did i have in here
i just had nothing i had like
let's say hi whatever content i had in
there itch
likes none cool so i can just get rid of
that right
cool cool i think we're back to i think
we're back to where we want to be uh
close enough let's see h64
green for flow auto b
all right we're getting there and now
why is my content
not being shown here
all right so we've got a we we're
missing b where has it
where has it gone away it's a uh flex
auto overflow y
auto what have i done uh h64 yeah cool
so
these these boils that i had from
that would be border get cool yeah yeah
cool so these things that we don't care
about
those can go away so i'm still
inheriting some of the styles that we
had mocked out for this little container
here so that was uh
it was restricting the size that we were
able to expand too cool so again um
similar sort of layout right so we've uh
we've mocked some of this content out we
uh our little section here c is actually
slightly too big so
um that is actually helpful to just you
know give these colors and see just
super visually um
like is that roughly the right size and
then you can start to see so
a here let's uh let's pull that out
this green a section uh let's quickly so
again before you put any content in
there
you know it's going to be a flex row um
justify between
item center so this is going to be a
super common right like if you want
things to be
between each other and on along the same
line uh this can be a super set of uh
utilities
um which is cool so i know we
we're going to have two sections of
stuff so we'll have one over on the left
and one over on the right so this uh
looks like title section
let's put some dummy content in there
for now and
there's gonna be a bunch of buttons
let's just make these buttons
let's make these uh some stars for now
nope not more divs stars please
thank you cool so now those are little
icons which we'll use as placeholders
for buttons just now
uh if we wanted to we could come back to
that a little bit later and uh
flush those out to be actually buttons
with hover states and active states and
all that stuff uh if we've got time so
let's see flex
flex call um so i'm making this a column
because what i'm looking at here is just
this stacking of like the name on top of
the little uh
this other input so let's see um
[Music]
these probably have some space between
them as well maybe only one or whatever
um and this does this get to be a
heading as well
um who knows let's let's make that a h3
uh let's make that a name
semantically not super important so
let's actually not make an opinionated
uh
opinion semantic decision on that now
let's just say that that's strong we'll
obviously do a an accessibility pass
uh if this were to ever hit production
cool so we got
nikola let's give it a full name
tesla and what is this content below it
let's just say this is some text right
we don't
necessarily care i don't necessarily
care about what exactly is in here
but we know that it's like small muted
text so um
small text great 200 or whatever
and this is
it's unmuted text cool so those are
stacked on top of each other if you go
back to our page and see
that's that's an input might it be worth
putting an input there so you can show
like placeholder colors and things like
that
oh yeah good idea yeah let's do that
and
can we do type text let us do that
are those self-closing i always forget
let's find out
uh i know we can get rid of this red
because that's no longer helping us
whenever we've got light
light content of course it's way too
late
it needs a value right of course
um let's see
uh can we just placeholder
cool uh let's make that a little bit
darker
why not cool uh i actually haven't used
this placeholder um
let me see
oh placeholder look at this
wowie that's excellent placeholder gray
300.
oh cool brilliant
cool yeah so there's a bunch of
utilities uh here that i
actually haven't had had the chance to
use yet but that's what's brilliant so
and then when the actual content is
there
can we set this to be say like uh just
regular text black
cool uh but of course that is actually a
value not in it not a placeholder and
so oops
placeholder abc and then as soon as i
interact with it and give it a valid
black cool yeah wow good old tale and
well done
um cool so that's great so we've got
that uh roughly sort of marked out
and let's give this a bit of padding
give ourselves a bit of room
uh now i notice that maybe maybe it's
also maybe not during this past but we
might come back to it like
it's got a dashed bottom border and
things like that
oh yeah things like focus states and
okay yeah let's uh let's spend uh
a minute or two just fleshing that out
so border um
is it dashed yeah and
border b again so these utilities are
sort of split up in a neat sort of way
where it allows you to set different
properties on the border
and so like the style and the the size
and the color and stuff so
um border like style so these are all
separated out into like solid dash
whatever so you can sort of compose
these to get the thing that you care
about so like uh
dashed for example that we i think we've
set did i yeah cool it's attached
let me start at the bottom uh what else
do we set uh
cool so that's already looking you know
somewhat close uh let's see
how are we getting on okay so it's only
on hover that we set the dash so yeah
fancy fancy stuff uh so let's do that
hover and focus i believe hover on focus
makes sense
and those get combined together which is
cool
oh interesting it's not uh
it's not doing that for me to be
borderlashed
hmm is it because the outline is
covering it oh possibly do we have an
outline on this
we don't cool yeah so again tailwind
quite handily has some nice uh utilities
about just
setting the outline for example by just
saying outline none
so let's do that so we don't want that
uh user agent style sheet default
outline let's get rid of that
okay cool it's not setting it for us um
i am slightly perplexed
is there a chance that the default
config doesn't come with hover for
border
no i don't know it must because because
our our yeah this
we were allowed to use it here um it's
probably uh
let's let's not get bogged down and it
might be configuration that might be
we're doing something wrong but uh
yeah cool i trust that this this is
achievable using the tailwind utilities
it's just we're not gonna we're not
gonna spend 10 minutes uh
uh spelunking to find out what exactly
it is so let's remove that because we
don't actually
let's not have code here that's not
doing anything for us just yet uh let's
just say it's always dashed
cool border beat uh let's just say it
all
it is always dashed and that outline
none is actually still good and text
placeholder cool so we're still we're
still super close here uh we just
haven't got the the perfect uh
interaction hover state
and but that's not what we needed this
first pass cool and we put one star over
here let's put a couple of those let's
um perhaps while you're at it you can
change the placeholder to
whatever the intercom one is oh yeah
visual idea
yeah conversation title
that sounds more useful than abcd uh
cool and now let's
make this just put these beside each
other
um and item center we don't care about
justification
here because it's just some content
aside uh
beside each other so let's have four of
those that seems like a lovely number we
actually have five here but yeah we'll
not get bogged down on that
and probably some space between hey do
we want to actually spend a minute here
and
turn these into sort of hoverable
buttons or do we want to flesh out this
uh this main content first
um i guess we've about half an hour left
so okay like
if it's good if you think we have time
yeah let's fly the
let's fly show the main content and then
we can make a call and what's the most
interesting stuff for us to look at
after because you mentioned the little
uh
relatively positioned status indicator
over there as well too which might be
interesting look this is a little bit
more
sort of a nuanced um ui polish than this
sort of layout problem that we've been
trying to solve here so far
um cool so let's uh let's
i should focus down to the rest of this
sort of main
inbox like conversation stream uh here
and let's see what else we have so we've
got green let's just leave that as green
for now because we can get to that in a
second
and uh let's flush out this so this
doesn't need to be blue but it can have
a little bit of padding right and then
we put our little
input in beside it um let's make this a
four or five or something who knows
um and then this it's not gonna be
perfect but let's just mark this out as
a text area for now
um and let's see what's going on
cool so we've got we've got a lovely
text area here that's great
not exactly as fully functioned fully
featured as the as the inbox composer
but we're getting close
let's see um let's make this full width
and we can actually just make it full
height as well uh because
it's uh it'll be bounded by the size of
the parent and we've already given it a
fixed height
um so again these are just height
utilities
and let me show you here i wish it would
clear that after i've found a search but
that's okay
um so there's different like these um
unit values and we've also got like auto
one pixel full screen so if you've seen
us use screen at the very top level like
application
wrapper sort of div and foil is just a
super handy utility for height 100 um
this is one of the things that
before tailwind like this lives in so
many classes around our app so it's nice
to be able to just say
very very explicitly this thing is
getting high 100
in the template it's super super
readable so we can yeah
hopefully to be full um what does it
look like here so we don't actually want
the outline so again we can use that
outline none
utility oops
on this high cool but we do want a bit
of a border and
um again we can
make that oh no blue with some number
probably 400
and that blue on hover cool so we're
getting close
make that a little bit darker and let's
round that
cool let's give it a little bit of
padding as well
again i'm just picking four here because
it's a nice round number it's easy to
type
we will uh we can come back to that and
tweak that after but
let's see cool so we're getting close
here right of the hover
and let's see let's
set that to focus as well um so again
super handy we can just set this uh
to select your prefix
focus cool so now you'll notice whenever
i'm typing in here and i move my mice up
over to here
it's still it's the same focus so again
you can achieve all these
um nice interaction patterns just using
simple utilities
uh so anything else we need to flesh out
there trust me
oh yeah shadow yeah shadow let's do that
lg probably
large shadow close enough that's that's
looking good
look at that um cool so we'll park that
there for now you'll trust me that we
know how to lay out content inside this
there's nothing groundbreaking about
what's going on inside here
um so that's cool
and now we can uh
what do you call it refocus on this main
sort of scrolling container of where the
actual messages are coming in
um so one thing that i believe we can
just steal directly from production here
is this lovely little background
so let's uh let's steal this lovely
little set of squiggles hello you
um we would you believe tailwind doesn't
have utility for applying intercom's
conversation background uh image so
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
inline this one for now
uh of course this could live in custom
css it's one of these things that where
for super custom things like this you
could configure your tabling config if
you had a set of backgrounds but
you know it's not the worst thing in the
world to have a css file with a couple
of very domain specific
um settings like this so say if i go
back up to here i make this not blue but
actually
sorry not green but i actually have a
forgive me an inline style tag of
uh background image is this big long
messenger thing let's uh
let's split that out and just to show
you what i'm talking about here
it's not the worst thing in the world to
to have some domain-specific stuff
alongside your
utility classes so we can do that here
uh my linter is going to keep screaming
at me for no inline styles that's fine
we can live with that stream
and we can move on so we've got we still
actually got green here wow look at that
maybe we should submit that for design
create so we've uh
get rid of green here uh and we've got
this lovely
squiggle background that is absolutely
wonderful i love it
so we can let's actually get rid of this
padding top so you notice here before i
save the file
there's a bit of a gap between our our
lovely little composer here on this
background which is a little bit jarring
so let's just get rid of that by
overriding this like generic apply to
all sides all faces
uh padding that you can override that
with a little bit more specific of a
padding top zero just
be gone padding top um which is cool
so now we've got this lovely little
background which is uh which is really
neat and we can we can
put some content on top of that so let's
do that and let's flash that out let's
get rid of this so that i can see
um cool cool so we can we can
speed through this let's speed around
this and we can uh
get some actual conversations in here so
if class um let's make a conversation
what's that probably look at again we
can look at this
um let's take it one of these items it's
like
again this direction i suppose the first
thing to do when looking at these just
figure out which direction it's going in
this is going in row
so we can set that
flex row which is cool um and there's
probably some gaps between those let's
say
who knows two excellent um
and then there will be some more content
inside these so if we look at these each
one of these rows here
one of those will be one of the lines
one of the entries in our in our inbox
like conversation stream if you want to
call it that here
um so let's do that let's again
pull up uh he's around it okay it
doesn't actually give those metadata so
i'm gonna have to go back here and steal
this
steal this lovely user circle uh let's
pull that in because we know we're going
to need one of those a lovely picture
um let's
this is going to be like the actual
message itself if i go back here
oh it's actually blue of course of
course yeah cool and that makes sense
blue 200 it gets a message it's rounded
it has some padding um and again we can
super quickly mock this out so this is
like
some message it's a message text
um and again this is one of these things
it doesn't have to be super high
fidelity it doesn't have to be
um like actual dynamic content yet feel
free to mark these things out with just
sentences totally fine and
cool it's actually let's actually flip
this around so that the text comes first
actually i think it's easier if we
conceptually think about this as
coming from left to right to start with
so if we look at mocking up one of these
messages
let's do that instead so we're making is
one of these
let's do that
go some message text and that could be
gray again
um and it's actually close enough to
what we want here let's put some padding
on this lovely little
um squiggle background thing
put some padding here okay so now these
messages are off from the very side
which is nice
uh and one other thing i noticed is that
this top level thing that we didn't uh
didn't fully flesh it let's just give it
a border bottom just so that it
marks that
right just so there's a line here a
break between at the top and the bottom
so we can easily see
um padding doesn't feel like enough
right you know just beneath this uh
coca-cola so let's um
let's make it a little bit taller too
cool uh great so
now we can flush this out a little bit
more um how close
are we here yeah we've got some hover
state icons uh those aren't uh
aren't super difficult to implement so
we won't get bogged down on that yet
uh cool this timestamp we can put that
beneath it as well let's do that
so that's beneath the actual message
content um
so we can do that by just having this be
a div
and we'll let that flex auto if it wants
to
but this is the message content and then
again make this a flex
container some call and then we can have
this be another div
um i forget what the content is actually
supposed to be
three months okay cool so five hours ago
is close enough
of a message content cool we can make
that
slightly lighter and slightly smaller
cool so that's looking good actually we
don't want this to flex the auto um
because uh by setting flex auto on this
container it's to actually allow this
this
gray background to fill up the full
space and we don't need that sort of
visually heavy if we if you only have
this much content
so let's fix that let's go back and pick
a better flex uh
better flex property than auto and
one that we can use here is to do what
do we actually care about
it can shrink you can't auto um i think
the easiest thing is for it to just not
uh for it to not grow by default at all
um so we can just not set auto on it so
we can just have it be the default
uh which is cool
and i can still be a flex call cool so
that's that sort of does what we want to
um and let's test with some arbitrarily
long
some arbitrarily long message see that
it wraps around it does cool oh yeah
another example of our
of our icons getting destroyed by being
too small let's fix that
again just one thing to be careful of
setting these
legs none
let's see that that abortion space
properly cool excellent so now we can
get rid of this boyo it's a big long
text
um cool so we're sort of close there
right like we're getting we're getting
close to messages let's just put a
couple of these in the page
um let's see
let's make a few yeah let's just to
automate the scrolling let's make a
handful of these
um
cool and sort of conceptually you can
see anywhere where like we're sitting
down here and like to to avoid
repetition to avoid like copy pasting a
bunch of template
um anywhere where we do that or anywhere
where we're like repeating
uh you could see this being broken out
into its own component because those
sort of like natural boundaries of where
like
you know me copy-pasting this just
because i want a second message sort of
implies that it should have its own sort
of wrapper around that some sort of
abstraction at least at just the layout
level um
in an ember it's super cheap to just
abstract that away into its own template
only component there's no
javascript backing that it's just just a
template abstraction so we can
pass in properties and change content if
we need to and
but let's do that so let's see let's put
10 of them beside each other probably
gonna want a gap between some of these
spsy two or something probably four
would be a bit more
afford a bit more content perfect
yeah let's just put four between it uh
it doesn't need to be perfect there's
actually some uh
some dynamic spacing between these you
see here where we sort of collapse these
two beside each other because they're
from the same um from the same sender
directly but you know whenever you have
these alternating things or whenever
you've got statuses those uh
those fit through as well so let's see
um
one thing we can do is sort of alternate
the the
who is actually sending it so this is
like the admin sending the message and
this is the the end users of someone
interacting with the messenger so let's
actually flip that around
uh and let's make uh let's make a state
for that i think
uh we've looked at this i think it's
actually possible to to just flip the
direction so one thing
that flex has a concept of that we've
touched on is the direction
and direction and we can just set
reverse on this
um that should work right so we can
so we're not changing it to call such
that we stack on top of each other but
we can set flex for reverse and what
that will do is it'll mess with the
it'll mess with the order of our of the
children inside that container
uh so there's ways you can like
explicitly say you know you go here you
go here you go here
regardless of where exactly let's say
for example here
if i put this as one and this is two
right so in normal layout flow there's
no real way to like
aside from like floating things around
to like have
this the the div that's defined second
in our template come
before number one here in our layout
flow but flex will allow us to do that
quite easily so we can um
we can mess with the order here so let's
let's say if
let's see
actually do care about this index
and they have my local confusion here
it's just a little amber helper for uh
division and oh is it mod do we care
about mod
i forgot forget exactly which one we
care about here but it's uh let's just
say mod two so
every second one is going to be a it's
gonna be an admin message so let's see
yeah so every second one will be zero
and zero is false
numbers so sometimes it'll be true
sometimes we'll be false
sweet so it's yeah so dave wasn't right
there so mod mod is cool so let's see
uh cool right so now we've alternated
those so every every second message is
from the admin
let's give ourselves a few more here to
scroll um
cool and that's nice right because then
we can uh we can actually do is
um see so we this would probably
be if this were a component this would
be passed in as a single property so we
wouldn't have to keep redefining this
conditional but
one thing that we can you could use less
to just let you know
oh yeah yeah good shot good shot that uh
that does indeed make sense so let's do
that
uh oh i can just i can just do that yeah
yeah let
mod i2 as yeah from as
yeah nice
from admin cool and
now we have that so we don't need to
keep repeating that conditional because
we're going to have to use in a couple
of places here so then if
from admin not aiming
if from admin we can set that
and let's close our lap block here
cool and let's check this how are we
getting on
my indentation is a little bit off here
and there we go fixed
so let's make sure that still works cool
yeah those are alternating and now we
can use that conditional again to to be
a little bit fancy about how we set this
so if
from admin amen
so if it's from admin we want this to
actually be
blue all right so you can use these
utilities uh
with some like dynamic state to change
the ui based on
some application conditions so so that's
handy right so as soon as we play that
hopefully yeah cool so that makes that
blue 200 that's way too heavy um
but uh you see here maybe we made that
100 too um i'm not a designer here so
you'll have to trust me that this is uh
close enough to what we're looking for
um cool so now we've got um these
sort of the direction happening you sort
of see like
depending on the sender they're sort of
mirrored so we can just do something as
simple as reversing the direction
uh one thing that i think we actually
need to fix is that this
this gap is wrong i think the the space
utilities have a special way of
um space between they have a special way
of
understanding this yeah cool especially
with understanding this
change in direction so let's
let's apply that to this place where we
are setting the reverse
spacex reverse cool and now that gap has
come back right cool so yeah so
there we are we're super super close
there perhaps the colors are the grey's
a little bit
light it is close let's go back to 200
yeah we're getting close look at that
um cool so is there anything interesting
yeah and just as a simple example here i
didn't want to click that
as a simple example here we can uh just
show what
uh let's see
if i uh so say if this is the tenth
message we can
we can put some like status message in
here or something
so let's do that so let's uh
just to show you what this uh what this
sort of centered content looks like and
we can do that really easily so
um flex row
justify center right so it's as simple
as that and then you would have any sort
of dynamic content in here
let's see what we have you assign this
conversation to yourself
cool so apparently for the tenth thing i
did that
so let's do that and see what that looks
like
cool so that's center now and of course
we could make that small and
slightly gray
something like that
cool right so we're getting super close
here the contrast isn't perfect on that
but you'll trust me that those are
uh but those are close enough and we'll
obviously
fix those up as we go along so um yeah
so that's sort of like
you know if you take a step back uh
40-foot view ignoring the red bits that
we've skipped for
for for time sake it's not super
interesting content in there um
like we're pretty close right like
that's close enough to
a to an intercom inbox to me um so
is there anything in particular you
think we could uh take a look at
uh no this is great specific the last
thing i'd be interested in seeing is
just
uh the icon and the left menu
uh that just is positioned in a
different way
yeah right yeah yeah i think that's a
good example of like something that's a
little bit more
um finicky a little bit requires a
little bit more finesse than just uh
laying out boxes on the page let's do
that
that's cool let's pick uh let's pick an
icon um
look at that hero icons well done uh
they've got an icon for this let's go
back up to our scaffold of content to
the top here which one was it
the second um so we go back to our
scaffolded content here
and instead of instead of it being
around a div inside there let's fill in
our icon
so let's do that and what did we want to
do cool so this a
tag so let's just pop that in and make
sure that still looks correct
slightly too small
cool looks excellent that's uh that's an
inbox logo uh
cool so one thing to think about when
doing this is that
so we know what content we want to go in
there so we want it to be a circle with
a red background and a 5 inside it so
let's just do that we can do that
and leave it in the normal layout flow
so let's do that
um 500 or something um
we'll give it some fixed width to who
knows
it should probably be based on the line
height of our font that's going to go in
there
but let's uh let's just do that we can
make the text y because when we're going
to be on a red background
and there's anything else we need to do
there around it
i believe that is it and then we're
going to have the special
magic number five again that indicates
how many
unread conversations or open
conversations i have uh
cool so we're getting closer that's not
big enough text
probably xs would be nice and we
probably still want that to be something
like 12 pixels
um so let's see what this looks like
still too small
oh and yes we want it rounded full so uh
two-win has a nice uh a nice utility for
for building circles which is basically
just setting rounded to full so it sets
it to 50
or whatever it is ah nine nine
many many uh many many pixels um
but you can do that to basically turn
out turn it into a circle if you've got
a
full background um so that's cool
yeah circle great i've got got an
example for that um
cool so what do we look like now close
enough
we're slightly still too small
we'll get there eventually and to center
this you'll notice that our our five is
slightly off and
we could probably just text a line
text center i'll be getting on there
that's close
and again to just show you what that
looks like
align text um oops
you can go left uh left center right
justify uh again of course
if you can think that there should be a
utility of some of these things there
normally is so
uh that's cool so what have we what have
we done to the page now we've put
a five beneath the inbox logo close
enough like you know
at a pass if that was all you could do
that you could ship that that's fine
uh but let's position it over the top
right hand corner um and the way we can
do that so
to get out of the normal layout flow of
the page we can make this
uh make this absolutely positioned
so we can make this absolutely position
and what that's going to do is um
take it out of the normal layout flow of
the app it's taking it out such that
it's not taking up any more space so
here if i
zoom in to show you what this looks like
you'll notice that uh beneath this icon
um
so beneath the inbox icon the second
like placeholder icon comes straight in
there's no gap between there
and this you could think of this as like
floating hovering on top of the rest of
the content
and so that allows us to then position
that wherever we want so tailwind has
some nice utilities around that so
we've got some layer utilities for that
if we look at the docs about you know
placing some absolutely positioned
uh content somewhere uh so we can set
top zero right zero let's do that
on this container
and i suppose we can already tell what's
going to happen here it's going to
disappear in front of our very eyes
because
what we've done is told it to go to the
top uh to the top and to the right of
something we haven't told it exactly
what yet so it's going to go to the
viewport
it's actually going to go to the closest
stacking context or you know the next
relatively positioned element so let's
actually tell it where
we want it to be constrained in so this
like a tag let's
let's say that this is our relative
container we can make that
now live exactly within um within this
container
so um we're getting a little bit uh
maybe lucky here that this
is actually the wrong size you you know
for for accessibility purpose and for
just
ease of use you'd want this a to
actually be the full size of the
container so let's actually make that so
with full i believe in the app we
actually just give these like
specific heights and widths so like this
would be
um we give these is it the full width of
the thing
right because you want to say tag this
whole thing to be clickable whatever the
law is of you know
moving your mouse to the full edge of
the page and still being able to click
on an a tag
that still applies here so let's uh so
let's do that
uh w full that's not uh that's not
helping us here
um let's make you a block
let's see how you're getting on
oh it's still not oh because there's
padding on that okay yeah cool so yeah
we don't need to get into that let's
just let's drop that for a second
batting four right because we want this
to be the full the full width so let's
see
the rest of these should be good
now
are we getting on on this would want to
be with
full also again that's another thing too
instead of flipping between your
template and the browser
um a bunch of browsers have cool dev
tools
and that allow you to to interactively
apply classes that are in scope so
classes that are on
the global style sheet so we can just
set here um
like we can set w full on this to to
test out and see what that would look
like if i just
set that to w two or four like you can
see this interactively so
uh it's a nice sort of interactive uh
interactive sort of debugging experience
people have set that cool so that now
that we've tested that that works in the
app
we can set this to uh to w full what we
could actually do is to set
this to be um
like flex auto but we don't we don't
necessarily need to so let's uh
let's just say you're you're the full
width uh and again i'm just going
through the
the layout here to show us that if we
need to position
uh this thing in a more sort of special
way we can
cool now this can be
justify center so are we getting on here
now cool
right so um what we've done there is
basically the same same trick that we
used to put the content centered inside
the card we've done that to inside this
a tag which is the link right so these
are actually links to other parts of the
app
away from the inbox but this is the
thing to the inbox and we want this a to
b as big as possible right
in that container so that we can click
on it and and
what we've done by making this like
justify center item center is just like
centered that svg
uh it bang in the middle which is
perfect um but this sort of gives us a
better sort of example of like when
you're inside this relative container
sometimes you don't get to decide
exactly you know my relative container
is the svg or whatever
if it's still a bit bigger you can use
tailwind to like reposition the
reposition this um absolutely positioned
element in
so um yeah if you wanted to you could uh
do we do we have specific top values you
could you could configure this with top
like you could say top you know
top four top five whatever we can also
just like nudge this in the right
direction with margins so if we wanted
to
um we can so this floating container
uh you can say margin right three or
whatever let's see what that gives us
so we can nudge this sort of into the
right into the right position
cool so that's brought it roughly in
line and we can give that a margin top
as well
which might bring it close enough to uh
to what we care about here
um and again it doesn't need to be
exactly pixel perfect uh we could
we could of course configure that as
much as we need to in our config if we
couldn't achieve it with the default
stuff out of the box but
um that's sort of an example of us
getting uh super close to where we need
to with this
uh let's make this uh
let's align our lovely little
placeholder icons here
by giving this uh there we go cool
and we can give this a nice vt5 or
whatever and this can get a pb5
um what i'm doing here is i had moved
this like entire wrapping container
around that primary nav that had the
padding on it all to just be at the top
of the bottom because
um we want the a tags to be the full
width of this container
uh just because it's uh it's good
it's it's good it's good accessibility
and usability
so cool um
that's great so yeah so that's sort of
an example of being able to
um i've been able to do more sort of
discrete um ui patterns small little
interactions like that you can still you
can still achieve those using
um using tailwind totally just fine um
so yeah that's that nice this is uh this
is great um
thanks very much i i learned absolutely
loads uh
i'm continue to be amazed with what's
possible with taiwan and how quick it is
and how much fun it is
uh so thanks for bringing us through it
coco cheers
see you later see ya bye